chris you've been very successful uh
you have really made a name for yourself
you're very well respected uh comedic
performer and
a very funny and an agile mind
yet i find this tragic when
you search your name on audible and
you've done you know you're a big
st you're a big name when you search
your name on audible
only porn comes up yeah only
porn yeah look at this this is
right here we have older [ __ ]
banged hard um
hard as it gets this has to do with your
last name is that right
yeah i mean i think i think maybe the
first time we met
we we got a good laugh out of the fact
that my last name
does spell out the words get hard that's
just a true
sad fact about my life so when you
search my name on audible yeah the
number one search result is older [ __ ]
gets banked hard because get
and heart are both in there but the
thing that makes me really sad
because i've been hearing that joke
since middle school yeah i can get used
to that
the thing that makes me really sad is
i've written three books
and that like i wish that was at least
number four
you know yeah i wish older [ __ ] gets
bengaard
came in after my actual written works i
don't even think i'm in the top five
of books that come up when you search
get there it's all pornography
right it does occur to me that if you
did porn
your name would be at the top talk about
a cash cow
right there yeah because your name is
get hard and then you could put get hard
in the title
and you know
i bet there's tons of people watching
right now looking at this going
yeah let's make that happen i really
want this guy to segue into a
pornography career
don't put it down i'm listen chris
i am also pigment challenged i'm a very
pale sickly person
i tried it like in the 80s for a year or
two
and uh yeah didn't go well but it didn't
go
horribly is there any parody porn about
you
that's a big thing parody porn right uh
yeah i don't know that there is i mean
let's put that out there again to the to
the viewers if uh
if anyone out there knows of any conan
with bonen
monin um you know please don't make me
do the work for you
let's just find if it's out there
because i want my cut
talk about cha-ching they they owe me a
piece
you know if not if they find some super
tall redhead guy who looks like you
and they give him a sidekick and they
name him the sidekick like randy ichter
and then they start that that that would
be that would be amazing
would you would you watch it yes i would
yes i would
i would watch it repeatedly i'd watch it
long after
um people could even think that it was i
was doing it ironically
they would just become clear that i was
addicted to that pornography